check out this crazy puzzle composed in  1966 by hustle the challenge is this  tell me what color all the pieces are  and what was the last move that was  played  such that this is a legal chess position  pause your video now to figure it out  all right here's the solution the  challenge was  from this position white has this pawn  on f2  black's king is on f1 white plays f  takes e1  equals a white rook putting black into  double check  this pawn has to be black because triple  check is illegal  and if this is a black pawn then this  bishop must be promoted there's no other  way for the bishop to get there  and as such these pieces are white these  pieces are white to avoid any extra  checks  and we have ourselves a legal chess  position  let me know if you like this video and  subscribe for more